all righty then it is time for drew's
news your fresh news linguine and a
creamy
good news sauce and with me at the desk
is my trusty co-pilot ross matthews
yummy hi
thank
everybody
okay so first up in the news today
is a little keeping up with the
kardashians although i don't believe
that's what we're calling it anymore
because they are back with a new show
proving they are yet again an open book
so just last summer they said goodbye to
the old keeping up with the kardashians
after 20 seasons that's a very round
number
um but now people reports that they're
back and bearing all the goods on the
kardashians which is their new reality
series coming to hulu
on april 14th and we have a trailer hot
off the presses take a look
over the last year
we have seen such transformations from
all of us
this is day one
okay
yeah i know
i mean ross yes
you're gonna watch oh you think yeah i'm
gonna are you all gonna watch hello i
wanna know
you know what's so interesting about
their show always is we know kind of in
the headlines the pop culture headlines
what's going on with them but then when
the show airs we get to go deep and
think about what's been going on lately
with them i mean kim hosted snl then the
pete davidson then the kanye of it all
than the tristan of it all then the
kylie with the baby and the courtney and
the travis hello i want
all the deets and they're gonna serve it
up i know they will i i never watched
the original show because i'm not the
biggest reality tv person as you know i
know um but i feel like if you didn't
watch the show and i've always followed
that like i'm always i'm
right up with you know i do keep up with
the kardashians
um and you don't have to watch the
television show to be an aficionado of
them because they're everywhere but i
feel like this one i could jump into
because we're kind of up to date and
there's so much going on and
you know maybe it's a 2.0 it is a 2.0
and it's not like the godfather
where you have to watch the first one to
get the second one you know you don't
have to have to have watched keeping up
with the kardashians to get this one you
can just jump i am one of those
psychological persons where i'm like oh
there's 19 years i gotta catch up on
forget it this one is a fresh start so i
think i'm in i'm in two all right we'll
be watching that coming up all right
next up we've got a man from new jersey
shore who got a shocking seafood
surprise listen to this the new york
post reports michael and maria spressler
were out at their favorite restaurant in
cape may called the lobster house when
michael ordered his usual clam appetizer
delish except this time on the 12th clam
he bit down on something really hard and
you th as you can imagine michael
thought oh no i lost a tooth but when he
spit it out it was a pearl
a curl i it turns out the 8.8 millimeter
pearl could be worth thousands of
dollars now that's what we call a winner
winner clam dinner the only thing a clam
ever gave me was diarrhea thanks so much
he gets a pearl that is winning the
appetizer lottery i know i love like
thank god he didn't swallow it i know
what can you imagine even if i swallowed
it i'd still be getting it back
i don't want to go into details but
they're deciding if
michael's wife is going to make it into
a piece of jewelry and he was like well
let's get it appraised first before we
do oh i say sell and collect the clam
[Music]
hey
yes i'm proud of you
[Music]
you